- One of the things you spoke about
during the pandemic was keeping
track of our mental health.
And we touched on it a bit here.
How is your mind doing through everything?
Mine has been a rollercoaster!
- Yeah, it's definitely
been a roller coaster.
You know, I've been very open and vocal
about growing up with
mental health challenges,
and that that's a continuing issue
for many of us who struggle.
Also, the notion that
it's okay to not be okay.
That's some of the messaging that NAMI,
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
tries to really spread the word about.
I'm not gonna sugar coat it,
it's been incredibly taxing
for many of us, especially those
of us who struggled before.
I'm an introvert by nature, which means
I don't mind being on my own
and not really going out a lot.
- Yeah.
- But the notion
that that's being chosen for me--
- Yeah, the option has been ripped, yeah.
- Yeah, it can feel really isolating.
And you know, my temper's been short.
My sleep's been weird, I started
getting heart burn again.
Just like all the stress things.
But those are all stress
things for my body.
And also, I was talking with a girlfriend,
and even my lady cycle
has felt more emotional
during the quarantine, like
everything is heightened.
And my mom has a pinched
nerve in her back.
She never had that before.
And I said, we're all stressed.
We're living in masks, we don't
know what tomorrow brings.
The news is insane, the country's
falling apart it feels like.
It's very stressful, even for someone
who has zero history
with mental health stuff.
And for those of us who have OCD,
there's plenty of things
to have new obsessions
and compulsions about, I promise (laughs).
- I know, definitely,
it's been a rollercoaster.
I have suffered from depression.
And it's like one of those things
where I don't do well,
and I'm an extrovert,
so this like not seeing
humans and not interacting,
I like really feed off of people's energy.
- Yeah.
- And I love the people that I've chosen
to surround myself with in my life.
So yeah, I've definitely missed
even like my glam squad, you know?
I don't miss glam, I love what they do,
but I don't miss the
hour of sitting there.
But I miss them and I
miss talking to them,
and I think all of us are like that
with work and stuff--
- Well, and you can
only do so many Zoom
meetings, you know (laughs)?
- Yeah.
- You can only do so much.
And even socializing, it's not the same,
and you have to use
your voice differently,
and you have to worry what I look like,
and I end up just like staring
at myself the whole time,
and like why do I look like that?
That's not helpful either.
- Yeah, I don't even do that.
I just never look (laughs).
That's the key, just don't look.